[Music]
you mentioned their kids there's two
kids kids around and there's a busy
schedule yeah so how do you how do you
keep the kids out of out of your area so
to speak well we we had a lock on the
door but then they figured out how to
open that so then I had to put a
deadbolt and then they really don't like
not having access to mama and daddy and
our bathroom has like a little patio
door and that goes to like an outdoor
patio but the dining room also has a
doggie door yeah yeah he they go so now
they go out the dining room alongside
the house and come around to the
bathroom door
so while double-bolted like okay we got
ten minute hop in the shower and and all
of a sudden you hear momma dad it's me
starring in story and what are they not
only noting the door they knocking on
the shower door about oh I thought
you're in the shower and I'm like
there's a curtain and it's a fogged no
you two can't see me okay good god no
what a house of horrors I was no no but
that's like you know we're like that's
the music we make love to in the morning
you're trying to be romantic in your
herring mama no no that's not gonna work
that's what life becomes you know we
used to make love to Prince and now it's
like our kids banging on the door yeah
sex hey that's a time are you uh you you
look fantastic you always do you must
work out constantly no I really I don't
I've been doing 14-hour days on the show
and I have two small children so it's
like lunges while I'm brushing my teeth
honestly in the morning I plunge why I
don't that's the only time I have well I
do lunges
I know do you like push-ups before bed
but yeah I'll just be doing lunges I'm
usually naked cuz you're naked when
you're doing the lunge we just important
to brush your teeth before you get
dressed because if you get toothpaste on
your shirt it's that's it you got to
change your shirt never to face I've
never brushed my teeth naked I don't
brush my teeth I don't I don't brush my
teeth do people do you brush your teeth
naked I don't oh you do I mean I have
it's not a regular
it's Hollywood only when he comes over
Andy so you like take off your you'll
take off your clothes
to brush your teeth well I know this is
a pretty exciting household
[Applause]
I gotta I gotta bring these stories home
I'm gonna drop by sometime unannounced